there's worth this is this is the
Whizzer weird story yeah you know more
about it than I do I didn't really read
Facebook removes Trump ad that
identifies and Tifa with red triangle
similar to Nazi symbol now I want to
stop right there it's not a Nazi symbol
okay it's it was a symbol used by Nazis
to identify prisoners but the reason I'm
drawing the distinction is that we know
what their actual iconography was the
the the Nazis didn't walk around with
this they did use it so I think it's
fair but I think there's a semantics
issue here and the reason I'm trying to
separate this is when you say that Trump
was using a Nazi symbol people are gonna
imagine very specific things yeah not
whatever this thing is all right but
I've chosen forward com specifically
because I believe they're a Jewish
publication correct I do not know I
thought right yes I'm pretty sure they
are so I want to get their perspective
and then I got Breitbart which counters
this narrative okay but this is an
overall weird story for a couple reasons
one it's not a widely known symbol to
anyone for any reason I had never heard
of it and I and I've been covering this
stuff for a decade never saw ya I'd
never seen it never saw it right so if
you want to argue Trump his dog
whistling to who like to know a couple
hundred people like it's weird there's a
conspiracy that conspiracy theory on the
left that Trump did this to crop dust
get as close as possible to you know
Nazi symbols so that Facebook would ban
him and he could claim bias okay that's
a conspiracy theory though yeah it's
kind of a long stretch yeah but it it is
used by the left and Breitbart proves
this so it's an overall just totally
weird story yeah but the other big thing
about it being weird is how the media
contacts Facebook and says see this
triangle it's racist just so you know
just so you know yeah and then Facebook
goes you got it bans I'm ridiculous
there's another weird thing too and this
was let me just read this story real
quick I read it read it in to Facebook
post Donald Trump's for reelection
campaign tied the the loose network of
Anti Fog which he suggests is a naming a
terror organization to an upside-down
red triangle a symbol strikingly similar
to one used by Nazis and concentration
camps to identify political prisoners
and communists so they show the symbol
actually you can see it here on this
this is you know president
dangerous mobs of far-left groups are
running through our streets and causing
absolute mayhem the post reads citing no
evidence for the claim
are you joking do you need to put that
seriously please add your name
immediately to stand with your president
and his decision to declare an tyfa a
terror organization facebook later
deleted the ads saying the ads went
against the company's policy against
organized hate our policy prohibits
using banned hate hate groups symbols to
identify political prisoners without the
context that condemns or discusses a
simple this is not a symbol used by the
nazis like and i would be specific by
that it was used in concentration camps
identify prisoners okay
it wasn't on the uniforms of the nazis
it wasn't a pro-nazi thing they don't
fly the flag of this and it's not
labeled by any group as far as i can
tell as a hate symbol so what is
facebook saying so they go on to mention
you know what it was political prisoners
would wear a red triangle with a p on it
and you can see here the variations of
it but there are also other symbols that
were used and mind you this is all
really really disgusting stuff i think
everybody in the world you know but the
nazis are truly one of like the purest
evils we've experienced in this planet
they say yet rabbi yaakov Menken the
managing director of the conservative
Jewish group the Coalition for Jewish
values said he did not believe the ad
represented an instance of anti-semitism
by Trump or his campaign huh and instead
suggested that it was an Tifa that was
at fault for unknowingly using a Nazi
symbol an tifa's has been and is very
threatening to Jewish houses of worship
in schools etc Menken said citing
reports mostly false and exaggerated
who's running interference for antifa
here forward that anti foe was targeting
synagogues in some cities during the
recent wave of protests the fact that
Trump is fighting so hard against an
tyfa is only to the benefit of the
Jewish community Trump and other
Republican politicians have seized on
false reports of people along with an
tyfa inciting riots and cities yeah we
get that point but let's let's jump over
here where Breitbart tries to break it
down Facebook's excuse to censor Trump a
red truck hey red triangle has long
history as an tyfa symbol first of all
they highlight this an tyfa attract i
found this as well this image is from
2016 it is a red upside-down triangle I
also found this right here which is also
a very old symbol it is an tyfa an tyfa
2018 and it's a red
triangle and then this person points out
red triangle symbol of anti-fascist
resistance from a an anti-fascist
Research Center they show the red
triangle they also mentioned it's been
used in other books they also mentioned
there is a pin used in 1894 left-wing
militants they wore the red triangle so
there you go I guess I don't tell you
but I do find the story rather weird for
a lot of reasons one Media Matters comes
out and says Facebook let the Trump
campaign run 88 ads with inverted red
triangles and infinite an infamous Nazi
symbol I think that's a fake tweek you
know why forward which was very
defensive and offensive of antiva said
to EDS 88 is a very specific number
that's a lot no no it's a very 88 have
gotten the educational course on the
Magic the Gathering card that was racist
oh man there is it there was a number
associated with it and I'll just put it
this way H is the eighth letter of the
alphabet so Media Matters says this
maybe it's true but forward says - and
forward was not forgiving of Trump so
I'll say it's contested at this point
huh but I'll tell you this
Trump war room responded to not just
this week but a bunch of other ones
saying this is an emoji the red triangle
it's also a symbol widely used by an
tyfa it was used in an ad in an ad about
anti father it is not in the ADL's hate
symbol database and they show this image
right here which apparently is on some
website where they sell t-shirts like
somebody made the the graphic and
uploaded it and it's apparently an older
image but I do think it's weird that
Trump team is now responding to all
these groups to try and just like to
prove it wasn't a Nazi symbol or
something you know what I think I think
they didn't think anything about the
symbol right I think it was on purpose
yeah it would be really really weird to
use some fringe symbol in this way yeah
I agree I think if you dig around enough
you will find a ton of symbol so another
example of this is you may have seen the
image of the the it's the Gadsden snake
with the revolution fist crushing it
right there's actually an image used in
Nazi Germany of an arm with the Nazi Pat
patch strangling a snake and so people
are showing these two symbols to claim
the left is
now using Nazi imagery interesting you
can find anything probably from bunch of
different groups because of those lots
of different art there's lots of
different symbols that have been used
and I do think it's rather absurd that
it looks like yes now I disagree with
the the the widely wide use of anti fuh
and the symbol because I have not seen
it do you think they're gonna start
changing yield signs that yield sign
makes me uncomfortable every time I come
here and a field now I've heard about
this yeah
and I'm scared of red triangle oh man so
here pull this up oh here we go
we will dread its overt yeah its overt
affort arianism definitely the Gadsden
flag is supposed to represent the snake
saying if you if you come near me like
I'm there rattle it's a rattlesnake yeah
it's warning you yeah I'll stop I'll
bite you I will bite you if you come
near me but it's basically about leave
me alone yeah just let me do my thing
do you mind right this is the opposite
the fist is strangling the snake who
said let leave me alone think about what
that represents now their argument is
that but the Gadsden flag was been has
been co-opted by evil groups so I look
man these I I understand their point of
view these are the people who think the
okay symbol is it is a white power
gesture now right
they don't understand the concept of
symbols so I'll tell you this if you
believe that the association of a symbol
proves the into know what the person
like if you think that symbols can
change instantly if you think that
anything that's similar in any way to
another symbol for whatever reason milk
okay sign is that symbol no matter what
they intended okay then you just made a
Nazi symbol right there yep now I don't
have the image to pull up but it's an
arm with a with a snake wrapped around
it and strangling it and it says
something like the two evils or whatever
and it's a reference to like things they
didn't like you know and it was it was
probably racist or something in some way
I'm sure but you can probably easily
find it out if you're looking at I'll
try but so the point I'm making is if
Trump's red triangle is a Nazi symbol
then I'll tell you what then so is this
so as we will tread right it's the same
thing in a fist Strang
a snake that it yep oh yeah Adam found
it it didn't take long right right
because it's it's it's a known Nazi
propaganda image all right yeah you
don't you want you wanna pull it I'll
get coordinated yeah we are we're not
one top one it's all good I did not know
that about the Nazis yeah well here pull
this up here we go
so this is this is an image that as far
as I know and it's actually the image
here is cropped because there's a lot
more but it's probably better that way
because I mean mu Gia's gonna YouTube's
gonna ban this video whatever could you
know cuz we're showing so what was this
no now show the other one now the fist
mm strangling the snake used by Matt
seem awfully familiar
and it's a and it's a red and black flag
who else used red and black you see my
point is look I don't really think these
dumb kids here understood what they were
doing no but they're gonna but the media
is gonna come out and say Trump knew
what he was doing they were okay what
your mastermind and now I'm seeing on
faithful people saying can you believe
that Trump red ran Nazi symbols for his
campaign I see it too and it's like are
you serious - did you look into it at
all no you don't my response is what wow
that's crazy dude did you see those
Antipa people also flying the Nazi
symbols and look at what that's not true
but yeah dude the snake strangling the
the fist strangling the snake and
they'll go that's not what that means
and I'll be like well I mean you just
told me a triangle where this one's way
more legitimate lead authoritarian like
clearly it is and it's and it's it's
extremely specific yeah that's true but
come on man do these kids do they really
know I don't think they know anything
about Nazi Germany or anything like that
I think they they have the two flags the
Gadsden flag and the fist and they
interpret the Gadsden flag the way that
they're Colts tells them to yeah that
it's evil so they made a flag to oppose
it you know it's authoritarian it's
creepy and yes it's very similar to it's
not ilysm it's Nazi iconography they say
so I'll tell you what you want to play
this game we can play this game every
single thing they ever do we'll just
pull up a bug oh look oh they're doing
it again
yeah it's like anything they use
you ever you have a an X the Bluetooth
symbol it's a room I think it's Danish
or something yeah it actually is based
on a king oh is it yeah it is bluetooth
yeah this image is rather crazy though
man yeah it is
so I tweet I didn't literally mist I
said I said so they're admitting to
being fashion so they're just admitting
to being fascist now and collective
squealing came from the far left and I'm
like I'm I'm insulting you okay I don't
literally think like I'm insulting you I
understand you're authoritarian
communist and there's a different in
that in fascism okay please calm down
but yeah that's I mean if we're gonna
start playing this game and Facebook's
gonna ban these people I I gotta I gotta
think maybe Trump did know what he was
doing and then I'm not Trump personally
but his campaign seems to be pretty
crafty hmm but I this is a weird story
man cuz I I can't imagine it was on
purpose this really does feel like the
Trump team didn't know what they were
doing
I've not seen the red triangle used
before right I really doubt they started
digging through Nazi history and they
were like there we go yeah the one
symbol we'll use why don't they use a
Star of David or why don't they was the
blue one or whatever
no it's I mean youyou it showed right
there on the bright particles
it showed antiva using the upside-down
triangle yeah as their their symbol it's
like okay so yeah I guess it kind of
makes sense what other symbol would you
would you say represents an Tifa I don't
look like oh yeah they do they have a
red flag a black and red flag
similar colors yeah absolutely
you know because it represents represent
labor and something else the libertarian
flag is yellow and black okay yeah so I
can't I can remember exactly why they
split the colors that way but then the
the the Communists fly a straight red
flag that's why the we will try to is
just red and then the anarchic communist
it's red and black which represents I
think communism and labor or something
like that I don't know God whatever well
welcome to the the world of stupid yeah
the complete world of stupid yeah so
nuts well the crazy thing is the
censorship that trumps ads removed it
wasn't running anyway but I do think
this story is weird I do think a story
is weird it's like I I think it's just a
triangle and I don't think you can draw
anything from it so you might as well
just ignore it
other than that but Facebook took it
down what if what if and that's in
saying it yeah red triangles are now
banned a bull offense I guess so that's
just weird
is there anything else the Nazis wore
their uniforms were brown are all brown
ups band is their slogan do for you know
I was thinking USPS is their slogan
really what can Brown do yes
unfortunately I they're gone what can
Brown do for you get canceled yeah oh
man
everything's gonna be out man dude
that's it that's the only a matter of
time before people stand up well I'll
tell you what don't thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you